je sais tout merci regardez ils sont
tous venus aujourd'hui tous venus car
ils n'ont pas travaillé ce week-end ils
ont besoin pour revenir sur neymar
malgré sa gastro il a joué il a été très
bon il ya pochettino qui est le nouveau
sélectionneur du psg qui a poussé un
coup de gueule qui a dit non il avait
vraiment une gastro il avait pas une
gueule de bois parce que tout le monde
disait qu'il avait une gueule match
suite à son anniversaire il en a déjà
marqué tout le monde tacle neymar oui
j'ai une en mai à récréer c'est vrai nom
est oui mais ok mais ça c'est de la
communication rennes pour un grand match
comme ça il fait que son anniv alors il
l'a fait témoin de manière moins
ostentatoire que l'habituel tefal
anniversaire d'isabelle morini bosc et
la folie mais quand même celle ci il est
pas très bien c'est parce qu'il a fait
la fête c'est une guerre trop
diplomatique alors la faute c'est le
chef d'établissement normalement qui
doit se signaler les cas qui doit faire
l'objet de telles décisions ou alors
vraiment je vous assure je suis pas du
genre à les défendre en principe mais il
fait ce qu'il peut avec la pression du
ministère du rectorat des inspecteurs
qui lui disent laisse ouvert laisse
rarement fait revenir les profs qu'à
contacter ou malades
il ya des cas le parisien on parle sud
ouest en parle france bleu on parle des
profs malades cas contacts donc sûrement
deviné consorts savent selon vous alors
faisons venir selon vous les directeurs
d'établissements ont des prérogatives
qui disent il faut laisser les autres
elle ouvert les écoles ouvertes coûte
que coûte
donc ils ont ajouté une seconde ils ont
des consignes camp mais clairement il
faut les sons et voilà fermer les yeux
sur certains cas entre guillemets le
coup du siècle que vous aviez préparé à
5 chacun 20 rôle précis et la cible
était identifié la star internationale
kim kardashian c'est lui qui était kim
kardashian moi du tout pas du tout quoi
j'en connaissais pas du tout ah ouais
pourquoi est ce que vous l'avez choisi l
appât elle s'est sentie avant qu'on a
choisi c'est son diamant on sait tout de
suite que ça vaut 400 ça dépend de la
couleur 4 5 6 millions d'euros donc là
on s'y intéresse parce que des acteurs
vous prenez 4 millions n'a pas renvoyé
ses larmes ça ça vous fait quelque chose
ou pas ça me gêne bah ça vous gêne bien
sûr c'est marrant moi je vous ai vu vous
marrez plutôt bons le sujet ah non ça
vous fait rire ça ne peut pas rien bah
si je vous ai une actrice c'est vous qui
me fait rire c'est vrai plus du talent
vous ne cherchez non
je vous vois arriver vous menacez en
plus souvent vous me chercher je vous
vois pas ce que je vous trouve pas
légitimes suis mais je m'en fiche
pourquoi je ne trouvais pas l'effectif
je m'en fiche sur quoi parce qu'il est
en train de faire l'apologie d'un crime
qu'il a commis
je fais aucunement j'ai je réponds
médias toujours pas jugée non mais ça je
dis tout de suite je suis là il regrette
il a rien fait mais il attitude son
livre j'ai séquestrés je trouve absurde
on reçoit ce monsieur j'aimerais dire
aux gens que lorsqu on confine on a une
perspective de déconfinement échos
déconfinement va regagner des libertés
le problème c'est que l'année sur un
plateau il dit on est stable dans
l'augmentation je sais pas moi mais
quand je suis à découvert si c'était le
cas des descentes des personnes votre
banquier quand vous avez moins 1000
euros et puis moins 1100 euros puis
moins 1200 et vous dis pas vous est
stable dans le découvert vous dis non
c'est complètement taré bon qui connaît
bien une autre témoin du jour je sais
que vous l'attendez loana merci d'être
là
merci beaucoup loana merci loana d'être
là alors on a plein de choses à te dire
oui déjà
j'aimerais qu'on voit avec toi tes
premiers pas dans le loft en 2001 juge
wheels à ce que j'aimerais qu'on leur
voix avant qu'on discute tout ce qui
s'est passé depuis
bien sûr tu va quérir une popularité
exceptionnelle
tu as vraiment plongé dans la drogue oui
c'est ce que tu dis bien suffit pas
c'est comment ça s'est passé
ouais c'est pas le loft comme on dit qui
m'a fait plonger dedans c'était les
mauvaises rencontres j'avais 30 ans je
suis tombé dedans
donc voilà et donc derrière
qu'est ce qui se passe il paraît que tu
disais tu dis un moment que tu prenais
de la drogue au petit déjeuner oui
c'était quelqu'un qui est alcoolique et
qui boit son verre d'alcool matin au
réveil et ben moi je prenais de la
drogue au matin au réveil tu prenais
quoi la cocaïne
c'est à dire donc le matin au réveil tu
te réveiller et je prenais jarle j'en
prenais je prenais un très haut et
jusqu'au soir n'ont pas dit comment
toute la journée et on tournait à
journée ouais mais tu as peur de
l'avenir
j'ai moins peur de l'avenir je l'avais
peur encore il ya quelques mois oui ce
que tu te dis que le plus dur est passé
le plus dur
passez ouais je n'ai envie d'avancer là
j'ai envie d'avancer ouais ça se sent et
je le sens à l'intérieur de moi oui tu
as envie d'être heureuse j'ai envie
d'être heureuse mais je crois que je
mérite bien sûr que si l'atteinte aux
libertés vous ne baissez pas les bras
quand il a créé une équipe comme le
confinement
j'étais avec jean paul stahl laisse
faire une dernière jean paul sartre
effectivement il est le confinement peut
être atteinte aux libertés bah non c'est
une atteinte aux libertés
toi parce que ces atteintes aux libertés
que c'est pas nécessaire c'est pas ça
que je dis jeudi qu' il faut d'abord
commencer par le commencement
et dire que oui une atteinte aux
libertés et que oui d'atteintes aux
libertés sont possibles si elles sont
justifiées par des motifs de santé
publique
ici c'est pas le cas et si vous vous
engagez je vous garantie un truc
mettez le toit ça pour le coup par une
spécialité en sciences politiques
mettez le doigt dans cet engrenage et
vous allez vous en mordre les doigts
à raison de 15 ans ou de 20 ans que je
peins stade y répondait à m division
alors je vous dis une chose je ne
comprends pas votre discours qui sert
certainement très juste moi je suis
approximatif et moi j'ouvre les yeux
moi je veux la rente qui craignent des à
biak six matchs par jour quelqu'un qui
tombe gagne alors qu'ils sont à temps
des buteurs il a été alors et quatre
fermées toulon est fermée il ya plus
d'icônes aux siens de se dire tiens dans
ce sens calais monsieur monsieur ça
s'appelle du ckpa jet monsieur s'appelle
du pathos et s'est pas fait non monsieur
massivement ses du pathos à part du
mandat chez moi quel sens et une
pertinence quand vous parlez alors parce
que si vous vous engagez sur le terrain
des airbus
est-ce que ça est effectivement ça
mérite un débat la scène d'où le fait on
a je vous rappelle effectivement
aujourd'hui j'en attendais le attendait
le cyclo
monsieur vous en auriez vous avez laissé
parler les gens vous avez raison de
souligner que la toxine hâtif
en fait j'ai on est venu me chercher
j'étais en interview à rtl qu'on soit
bien contexte avec eric emmanuel schmitt
c'est les flics viennent me chercher et
on m'accuse pas ce qu'on me dit que j'ai
fait un volet de violence un hommage à
sion je ne sais pas de quoi ils parlent
je dors la nuit en prison et je me rends
compte que j'avais une quand une
campagne à l'époque de sept mois qui
s'étaient vengés d'un ex et avec mon
téléphone elle a envoyé l'adresse de
l'ex pour aller faire casser la gueule
mais moi je tombe dans un truc et on
prend un avocat on sait pas en fait
quand on n'est pas dans ce truc là on
vous avait été lavé de tout soupçon
depuis mais n'ont jamais été lavé de
tout soupçon j'ai pris tellement faux
que ça manque quand même savoir qu'il y
avait plein de culot passion qui se sont
rajoutés des as cotation sécurité mise
par les médias qu'ils ont rajouté
rajouter et le procureur général avait
demandé cinq ans et demi de prison ferme
qu'on s'entende bien qu'il ya deux sms
et un oeil au beurre noir donc moi je
suis je dit c'est quoi ce truc je m'en
sors 30 mois de prison avec sursis ce
qui est énorme
bel exemple que c'est un monde de faux
culs ce nouveau service est pour vous ce
que cyril et il ya encore dix ans
n'étaient pas les alliés d'aujourd'hui
et à l'époque quand je n'ai pas pour
vous pour vous marchez dessus 10 ans
après les mêmes qui vont marcher dessus
sont présentés vous ça c'est la preuve
absolue pour moi que ce multi est un
monde de faux culs crée donc pour moi
c'est des faux culs et ça te vire du
jour au lendemain
journée demir et tous les matins virer
tu sais pas pourquoi
si vous saurez pourquoi mes attentes
même temps ou pour tous on y va tous
nous on aime ce métier
voilà on aime ce métier parce que c'est
un métier il faut être honnête c'est un
métier qui est bien payé c'est un métier
où tu veux ou tu es content il ya des
lumières il ya du maquillage les gens
quand ils viennent au boulot le matin
les maquis pendant les applaudit passez
un bon métier
donc faut prendre l'idée faut ancrer
l'idée en soi de se dire c'est un monde
de focus un monde hypocrite
le jour on va me virer comme benjamin
qu'il le 10 mars elle veut quelque chose
parce que tu es restée jusqu'à ce matin
du succès mais c'est patrick que c'est
les gens qui t'aiment
et c'est ça la jeune fille bah oui
les gendarmes et que faisait les jeunes
avant que j'ai fait moi c'était ça cadre
et moi j'étais un peu branleur quand
j'étais jeune ça m'a fait du bien de
faire un énorme émoi là donc c'est
quelque chose d'important et je pense
qu'il faudrait le remettre en place
puisqu'une majorité ici le veulent mais
avec une nouvelle forme un symbole qui
décide
oui parce qu'à part le général mais très
sincèrement on va boire je dors dans un
instant juste devrait voir la vidéo
bernard montiel oui alors moi j'ai fait
l'armée j'ai fait l'armée dans la mêlée
est rejeté de la base aérienne de
mont-de-marsan
c'était assez formidable j'ai fait
beaucoup de mérite - soleil la main j'ai
fait beaucoup avaient déjà un peu
d'argent en fait avec mon frère on avait
acheté cette bagnole allait payer
l'équivalent de 2000 euros je me suis il
était grave
il fallait la poussée c'était une
triumph spitfire jeu quelque chose on ne
je suis pas loin de ce qu'il vient de
dire parce que sous la question du
masque à l'intérieur j'ai souvent
défendu et même au mois de mars j'étais
parmi les premiers on conseillait même
le sopalin parce qu'on était dans une
charge virale très puissante mais preuve
qu'il n'était pas alors dans ces cas là
dans les coulisses mais parce que fait
la danse et bien gérée par exemple un
enfant deux enfants 7 e devant une
famille qui s'appelle un peu comme nous
il ya même benjamin et yato 90%
d'oxygénation 93-62 pulsations du coeur
l'autre enfant c 98 et 87 pulsations à
la sortie vous avez un enfant qui à 88 %
en plein délire
médiocres et des connaissances du
coronavirus et là vous venez
malheureusement devant peut-être un
million de personnes de vous dire vous
venez de perdre votre crédibilité et
heureusement